because I want to leave people with a
with a sweet taste in their mouth
I wanted people to leave their thinking
the Wake was awful but who was that
bread yeah he was looking flying
Sarah because that pinstripe that golden
black wakanda forever pinstripe was
looking mad
[Music]
as you already know guys we go straight
into the IG question and IG question of
this week was was the worst pickup line
you've ever heard and as per usual guys
the response Juicy Juicy Juice I'm
actually really excited about this one
you know I've been down my chin juicy I
was really excited because I usually
don't look at them but people were
sending me
um screenshots okay like me personally
okay of like oh for your question for
your question I don't know what the
question is so why are you sending me
this but obviously I thought all right
so
um
I'm gonna say them to you as if you're
the chick okay yeah and I want you to
rate them we'll do like a five-star rain
on all these Sailors obviously it's the
worst ones but a lot of them for me are
just funny all right of course yes I
just want to see what all right
I like my women like I like my ice cream
plus size and dripping down my fingers
that's a bit yeah that's a oh it's hard
because I I had this is the first one
yeah so I don't want to be the oh that's
a five yeah so I mean yeah it could be
dead yeah in comparison to what we get
but I'm gonna give that like a three
three and a bit all right three stars
yeah say less
she said she was going to climb me like
a tree I'm five foot five
where's the pickup line bro where's the
pickup line there is none
she must have been four for eight what's
up bro all right say less
how much does a polar bear weigh enough
to break the ice oh okay I'd give it
like a two that's a bit quirky okay but
I'm not giggling yeah I'm not giggling
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh your eyelashes real I closed my eyes
to show him and he tried to kiss me
ah
a
that doesn't leave
I said nah that's a soap right that's a
soul bro jeez that's funny Ah that's
jokes that is funny oh my God all right
so less
grab your coat you've been pulled all
right I've heard that one I was there
you never heard that that's that's an
awesome classic bro grab your coat
you've pulled that's classic we're
talking free was it uh what's that
um what's that old show three point
three points of lager do you remember
that show three pints of blue three
points of lager and a packet of
Christmas oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
like on Dave or something oh bro it was
before I think it was like
I want to say it was like BBC three in
like the early 2000s it rings about yeah
dead this show but I used to watch it
when at like 2 A.M I fell all right
she said she saw me on Saturday night at
10 30. that was her match of the day
hmm okay okay after four it's a four
that's a four yeah yeah say less
I like my women like I like my Advent
calendars against the wall flaps open
and ready to be eaten
okay that's aggressive
flaps open
flaps
[Laughter]
that's aggressive it's aggressive all
right I'll give that like a you know I'm
actually gonna unduck points because
that was a bit much yeah yeah that was a
bit more flaps through yeah flaps
through me that's like a two okay let's
say less
is your surname Malfoy because it's you
I want to Slytherin
I'll give that a four sailors
if I told you I worked at FedEx would
you be able to handle my package
[Music]
you know I'm gonna give that like a
three I think we could have done better
if we're gonna go package but yeah
that's not bad that's not bad that's not
bad
just go out with me I've asked you three
times already
yo that's funny that's funny oh Jesus I
give that a five that's a five bro
that's so funny dang
are you my appendix because I have a
funny feeling I should take you out
um okay okay not bad not bad it's not
bad I give the three
I'd love to take you to the movies but
they have rules against bringing your
own snacks um that's yummy
daddy that's yummy
I wonder I would give a five all right
we've got two five you're calling me a
snack yeah yeah
you want a snack a man in the dark room
stop
don't don't tease me like that
I want to bang you like the screen door
in a hurricane oh my God aggressive them
screen doors
they're slamming against the door wow
what's the difference between me and my
couch
hold on my couch pulls out
swear
I've never made a uh actually I have I
was gonna say I've never made a pull out
joke but I have what to a chick yeah I'd
I'd like to say I haven't because I
can't generally think of one but I
probably have yeah I probably I think I
have hmm all right let me tickle your
belly button from the inside
[Laughter]
taking it from the air from the inside I
don't know what it's like to have like
Fanny flutters but that would that would
run me him if he if he's banging yeah
that would run him to me that would my
legs would Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah from the
inside I'm trying to be in your gut yes
but geez
what's that
sweetly sweet
are you my laptop
because you're really hot and you're
making me nervous
like fan play bro when those fans kick
in and it's just game over yeah it's
revving it's like a Brevin yeah I closed
my laptop and flip it upside down dude
just give me some air close my lap so if
I flip it upside down like do what you
need to do do what you need to do
because you're making noise
that's hilarious I've never done that
that's too funny
do you want to play sharks I'll eat you
and you scream
no aggressive that's a one that's a one
that's too much say let's wanna play
sharks what
are you a bowling ball because I want to
stick three fingers in you
um I knew where that was going so I'm
gonna give it a two yeah it was obvious
where that was going
after he heard I went through a breakup
he said I love me some leftover Chinese
[Applause]
Jesus obviously she was yeah yeah
about that
I don't know how to feel about that jeez
what's it what's better than eating a
mandarin
go on eating Amanda out
that's not bad that's not bad that's not
bad it's not bad it's not bad I feel
like um but the thing is
it's not bad but if my name was Amanda
as soon as you said it was better than
eating a mandarin I'm like
here we go yeah I know where this is
going you're not eating me out
don't even do this
that's jokes
man said damn you're hotter than a spoon
at a crack house
that's hot
that's what I'm black
gorgeous
hot to the touch yeah yeah dead ones
bubbling
yeah that smack is bubbling on that
spoon that's jokes
are you into Birds
because I think you'd like a hook or two
okay I've heard that before not bad I
got a couple more or two as well like
what what yeah yeah yeah what are we
saying
because I'm I'm a top is what you're
saying it's an insult you and who
yeah
yeah
are you insulted me
waste man
did you fall from Heaven because you
look clumsy as [ __ ]
that's stupid
Oh my days brav
o
it's sweet the life Hobby
last one
are you a farmer
because you know how to raise a [ __ ] all
right say less say less say less yeah so
those were the worst pickup lines you've
ever received
Jesus that was fine that was hella funny
um but yeah I someone actually sent me
one so
dumb it was dumb she screenshotted it it
was I think it goes on like 10 to a
second and he said literally like are
you a fart because you blow me away yeah
stupid bro yeah I got loads of those
when I was posting them this actually
brings me on to my next thing not next
thing but I've been tempted
um I keep keeps coming into my head
um that I want to start but I just
forget all the time so now we're on the
topic what I would love to do is guys if
you can send us in
send us in some Tinder conversations
some we did ask we asked about this
years ago when we had zero Fighters
we're asking ourselves begging for
followers ask ourselves yeah yeah yeah
but yeah let's let's do some doesn't
have to be Tinder let's do some
um dating app conversations yeah yeah
either whether it's their open in line
or how the conversation goes or if you
want to know what their intentions are
what he said what she said just send
them in yeah
um and yeah we're gonna we're gonna
discuss it on this yeah we're gonna make
something because there's something in
there that I'm super interested about
and the ones that I have seen super
funny okay
um so yeah please send them in guys but
anyway welcome back to the show Welcome
Back you are back here with your boys J
Money And Fire Lord flakes yet again
guys every Monday
so of course thank you so much for
joining us facts um as always guys what
we need you to do is join the cult
babies
okay with the cold daddies we need the
cold babies we need more cult babies we
need a log cabin somewhere in the US of
a preferably a nice Open Meadow where we
can indoctrinate use we can have
breeding grounds and we just have keckes
and clapping cheeks and the way to
indoctrinate yourself into the occult
baby culture guys is head on over to
patreon.com
shits and gigs where you will be
introduced to the thousands of other
cult babies that we have over there that
enjoy bonus content from ourselves they
enjoy a back catalog of everything that
we've done on patreon it's uncensored
it's very unedited it's raw it's super
funny and it's a good time guys get on
the Discord chat about this that and the
other be the first to know about shows
be the first to know about new merch be
the first to know about everything and
obviously once we get the Log Cabin be
the first there it's gonna cost you
three pound a month NP a day you're
gonna need to run the pizza sng guys
over at patreon.com shits and gigs do
that now and then as soon as you get
back guys if you are watching watching
us on YouTube please subscribe we're
doing numbers in the subscriptions and
now I'm thinking wow maybe one day we
will hit a million I was saying it
before I was just saying it before but
now all 300 something thousand this
could actually happen it's gonna take a
while but guys tell a friend to tell a
friend subscribe to the channel keep the
notifications on when you know we're
dropping something new slightly hot and
lastly guys if you are listening on any
podcast platform any audio platform
please do us a massive favor and leave
us a nice review it means the world to
us as always five stars is preferable
but whatever you say say it with your
chest guys and without any further ado
I'm going to pass you guys over to my
brethren two my boy Fire Lord Flags who
is going to hit us with some knowledge
for today get the juices flowing it's
Monday let's go fun day let's go in 2012
after his girlfriend broke up with him a
Chicago man bought a car for 500 in her
name and abandoned it in an illegal car
park at the airport
the accumulation that the car
accumulated over a hundred thousand
dollars in parking fires which the city
demanded the ex-govern had to pay that's
impossible
amazingly calculated bro
bro how are we not just Towing this car
by the way bro I lie because it's been
it's been long now what happened if I'm
amassing so many fines just totally yeah
no one's about to get that's crazy bro
hundreds thousand dollars and the city
you said big man you're paying it I
don't care I don't care where you get
the money yeah what can we get the money
from Suzanne you're paying pay it you'll
shut up and pay it it's your car it's in
your name right she's a big big man it's
not mine and she probably doesn't even
knows him but she probably knows yeah
she knows she knows she could not even
bastard she knows exactly who it is oh
that's horrible that's treacherous
that's treacherous
I could never be that victim I couldn't
yeah because it like I've said this
before I only have a certain threshold
of stress I can handle before I just tap
out yeah yeah and I promise you I'll
move country like I just won't care
anymore like it's a point where the
council can never ring me and be like oh
this is your car etc etc you almost 100
Grand yeah and you have to pay otherwise
you'll go in jail I'm like well
obviously I'm not paying it so I'm just
going to leave yeah so just buy then
isn't it just gonna leave because I'll
just pack my passport and my face
expression won't change because like I
said I've only got a certain range of
emotions and as soon as it gets past
that Peak I just shut down I literally
just shut down yeah and I'm like cool I
just don't care anymore I'll put the
phone down pat my bags and I'll just go
to like Norway or something yeah because
I'm not paying you 100 Grand 100 bags
that's that's Sinister I wonder what she
did to deserve that oh 100 and on my way
to the airport I forgot to say I'm going
to his yard with a sledgehammer I forgot
to say it forgot to say on my way to the
airport I'm pulling up to his yard he
said I'm smashing everything to this and
I hope he opens the front door
I hope he opens the front door because
he'll be collateral damage yeah yeah
yeah that's not running a man could
never be like no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I'll Fish Hook his nose
I would are one million percent I would
shook his nose
bro I'll pull a Cersei yeah um on that
red keep episode I'm blowing everything
up I'm blowing infinite I'm walking out
of there that was an episode that was an
episode he was a villain oh Cersei was
the villain as soon as they locked her
hair off she
she stopped yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah as
soon as her hair got chopped off she
stopped caring yeah yeah it's really
about to be real yeah
geez Cersei was crazy she was crazy what
a throwback who's a um I'll say oh
Damon's the new crazy
oh yeah yeah yeah I was gonna say that
but I thought you're gonna say who's
another good quote unquote villain in
the show I was gonna say um uh the we
are Pines we are piones
oh what's her name Queen um Macbeth Nick
oh no it's uh um that's a sister yes uh
it is oh it is um from C her name is
sabeth
well played Sabbath turns out I was
never going to get it it's usually a
similar I was like
she's dark she's a villain I'm so far
behind I need to watch I haven't seen
anything else I've seen season three
I've seen sported right in three two one
I've seen her escape the the city I've
seen her up to her face and leaves
yeah yeah yeah yeah she was roughing it
yeah I've seen up to that yeah okay yeah
and then um I haven't seen anything else
okay yeah it's juice man it is juices um
it's real real good were you up to on um
For All Mankind
so For All Mankind I am I don't think
I'm much further than the last time he
spoke I haven't watched it in a few days
okay I'm on C obviously season one I'm
still on season one yeah so I'm oh okay
cool so
homeboy now knows that um spoiler winner
in three two one he knows this is son's
dead Okay Ed crazy yeah yeah he's just
been drinking yeah he's been drinking
grabs I can't remember what whiskey it
was he yeah yeah he's been drinking yeah
yeah
um and
the crew are now Okay cool so Apollo 25.
is it 25 or 24. I can't remember I can't
remember then what's going on right now
homeboy you're on season three you've
got time on your hands bro I do um I
actually do
um so they've gone up to get him they
had an issue
while they're up there so now they need
to send someone they need to send
the home girl yes up there yes yes yes
yes to get uh to go yeah they need to
send more people up there basically uh
to sort their ship out so they can go
get Ed yeah that's where I'm at right
now oh this episode after that oh
there's a because I didn't want to say
it because I didn't know whether it was
in end of season one or beginning of
season two because I couldn't remember
but there's a scene with you know the um
the chick that's uh claiming to be
claiming not to be a lesbian you're
married she's just got married yeah yeah
so she goes up she does a master in
space I swear yeah she does a marzer in
space yeah yeah yes yes so that's the
next episode less all right cool that's
the next episode it's um I'm telling you
the production and the visuals of what
they do in Space Jams is Bonkers okay
cool cool cool cool cool I'm starting to
enjoy it more I'm not gonna lie bro last
two episodes I told you bro I know
things you you told me I don't think you
taught me enough because not only was it
a slow burner it was the most boring
shot I'd ever seen oh it was slow for
the first four episodes slow most boring
show but you needed the context as you
look back now of course of course you
always do yeah which is why they waste
people's time but yeah it was so slow
and so boring
um I also haven't I'm not up to date
with bleach
oh I was the last episode you watched so
the last episode I watched was
um well maybe I am up today no I don't
think I am or maybe I am
because I'm up today so you can say
whatever
so I don't think no no I'm not up to
date I'm not up to date I'm not up today
the last thing I watched was Captain
Yamamoto doing a dirty Madness a dirty
man no southeast west yeah yeah
you saw what happened at the end right
yeah yeah I've never seen stuff like
that
the thing is when I think he started
with what Easter yeah when you said East
I was thinking gang but when he said is
a figure there must be three more yeah I
didn't think that they would show us
three more bro and he went after the
whole thing just for laughs just for
[ __ ] literally just for sure oh my God
he took us through the whole cycle just
for the sake of it I was like oh my God
he is a powerful he's too powerful
mother [ __ ] yeah do you know what I mean
and he went
um
so Overkill which in the scheme of
things Jarred me because he's done all
of this he could have X-Man off with
East true he could have done ran off
with East and then he went through the
whole shenanigan just caught he wanted
to prove to prove a point finally
duppied my man only for homeboy to come
back and be like you're tired in it yeah
you're a bit tired shame yank just yank
my hero my arm behind on my I'm behind
on all anime at the minute so I'm
I think I'm an episode behind on Blue
lock I'm three episodes behind on
chainsaw man so I'm excited to watch
that
um an episode behind on bleach and I am
uh an episode
two maybe two episodes behind on my hero
okay both my hero and Chainsaw man
you'll you would wish there were more
episodes oh I bet you would wish there
were more episodes I might just leave
chainsaw man because I haven't missed it
okay I enjoy watching okay but obviously
it's so early on I'm not emotionally
invested yeah okay I hear you I'm not
emotionally invested and a good thing
the good thing about it is that I hardly
I don't see spoilers anywhere so you
won't be ruined by anything like you
won't be like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah 100
um I
we might just leave change some mind for
the end of season if I can handle it I I
definitely can't do that I have to watch
it but yeah I'm because I'm so behind on
everything else yeah I can I can clog my
time with other stuff that I can watch
to let that carry on but I'm enjoying it
do you know why I did finish
um the other day which I stopped months
ago Tokyo Avengers
I finished I finished it last week
season two yeah no they're dropping it
next year okay cool at the next year or
December but I think it's next I think
it's January the the big fight in the in
that car park thing oh my god there was
surprised after surprise after it would
drop bro body yes yes yes Mikey is two
arms oh he's too much he's literally too
much oh yeah yeah when he was getting
the pole to the face yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was getting pumped up for ages
and he said swear you really want to be
my enemy I just went white you really
want to be my enemy yeah his eyes went
white when he raises mama was grabbing
his leg he raised his leg and then
kicked my man in the face
hopefully they give us a good backstory
of Mikey um or a bit more backstory of
Mikey in season two yeah because they've
given you a story of obviously what
happened to his brother yes but between
from what happened to his brother to him
starting the gang yeah we don't know
anything about it they showed us a
couple backstories of when they started
again
they didn't dive in yeah and no one
knows why you so arms no one nobody
knows apart from the fact that he just
is yet facts bro facts he just is and it
doesn't make sense that he could just
kick man in the head like that and then
sorry Scott you're gone again I've got
to say I hope um takimichi has some
actual Powers not Powers but like some
citing about him symbolics something sat
in some guts that's the reason why I
stuck because it was jarring he was
getting tamped up every single episode
he he takes L after L after certainly
it's such a little weakling he's useless
bro and they've made him captain now so
I think I hope to God they're fast
tracked it to like two years later for
season two and he's just arms and just
absolutely awesome so he is I'm looking
forward to watching season two but do
you know what I do want to start um I
know we're going on a little anime
tangent but
do you know what I do want to continue
watching again which I think you
internally you definitely enjoyed it to
me uh bongu stray dogs or whatever it
sword show season one
out in January yeah yeah and I'm not
I've definitely watched season one but I
can't remember anything about it and
season one was amazing I've I remember
watching a little bit of season two and
thinking okay I feel like every season
they change the story mad okay so I
don't know if it's completely continuous
okay
um but check it out for me because I
can't really remember okay I'm gonna
re-watch It Anyway God season one was
good I'm gonna watch season one God
season one was good tis the season for
clean balls
right guys it's manscape time it's
manscape time over there these lots are
helping you clear your driveway for safe
travels this holiday season
from stocking stuffers to gift exchanges
markets products at the top of every
wishlist facts grab some crop mops for
your pops or the shampoo for your boo
say less do you like love a little right
oh yes right a little alliteration thing
be the star of gifting season and help
all the men in your life go from eggnog
to nice hog
bro say less this December by going
manscaped.com and using the code guys
you already know what it is but let me
remind you one time the code is s n g
you already know Sierra November Golf
and that's going to give you 20 off plus
free shipping guys thank you so much
let's get back to the episode
um
right okay cool I've got a couple things
to talk about hit me
so yeah
Daddy finally got his test results okay
after like two months of this case okay
okay okay okay Daddy finally got his
test results okay so I I think this
might have been like purely patreon chat
I think I was gonna say give them
content so for context
um so guys um I wanted to test out what
my testosterone levels were saying um
because
obviously your boys are in the gym
lifting weight I'm not losing weight the
way I used to I remember when I used to
on a diet I used to just cut out sugar
for a week and your boy had all the ABS
all the [ __ ] guys the whole the whole
shebang yeah
um these days they're impacting about
that it's just not
it's not falling off like it it's not
falling off like it used to I remember
at one time so uh REM wrote me a diet
plan over summer before we went away
first two weeks I think I dropped first
week I dropped like five pounds I was
like gang second week I dropped like
three pounds or something like that I
was like let's go I'm on stuff the third
week I did like actual better yeah like
my I was stricter on the third week than
I had been the previous two weeks I
gained a pound yeah remember you're
telling me I wanted to start stopping
people
in fact I wanted to start get a box
cutter and just start doing stuff
and I was like what's going on doing
stuff
and you know um
and then you know you know what like uh
what's the film you know white chicks
yes but she's she's in the changing room
scene yes and she's like say hello
that day I gave the pound that was me in
the bathroom mirror just ass naked just
say hello quickie
um so from then I lost motivation so
obviously going through everything I
still train hard um I know my sleep
isn't perfect but basically what I
wanted to happen in my head I was
thinking to myself right I'm gonna go
and get my testosterone tested I'm gonna
go get my hormones tested and I'm gonna
see
wag one so I ordered the medical kit
um the company I used was Medi checks if
anyone else is interested it's actually
really good
um I think it cost me to get a full
breakdown I think it cost me like 70
quid there's a cheaper one for 30 quid
which is a little bit more basic but I
wanted a full breakdown 70 quid they
send you a little finger pricking so
first time guys I tried the finger brick
thing I couldn't
get blood out of my fingers to save my
life yeah I felt like Wolverine as soon
as I pricked it the thing was closed
[Music]
this is
was closed
so I was I I was panicked because you
have to give them a certain amount of
blood in this little vial so I I was
short on some blood yeah so I dipped my
bloody finger into my water bottle and
just dropped a couple a little healthy
drops of water in there but they're
never gonna know I'm 70 water do you
know what I mean I'm a human being
they're never gonna know but I'm just
vulvik up in there so I said it off to
them
they came back to me immediately and was
like
normally yeah normally anomaly normally
none of this is making sense do it again
yeah so they sent me a free one do it
again this time I pricked my finger it
was dashing up I was like gang
gave them the blood sent it off there's
Royal Mail strikes yes and they need it
it says on the package they need it
basically the next day they need to ASAP
the longer it's not and the longer it's
out they're like the more anomalies
they're gonna have so I sent it off I
remember I sent it off on a Wednesday
um there's a Royal Mail strike they send
you an email as soon as they receive it
they didn't receive it till the
following Monday for steak I was livid
absolutely so now they've given in their
mind all right this is strike two yeah
yeah they bailed me they bailed me and
said look is this James Ben is this
terrible you're playing at
but this time we can't risk any other
packages you're just wasting it in them
yeah so um they basically said you've
got two options you can pay an extra 30
quid and go to one of our local clinics
um and uh they'll just take your blood
there you drive they'll take your blood
that's an extra 30 quid or you can bet
an extra 50 Quid and we'll send a nurse
to your yard yeah I Googled the closest
clinics the closest one was like 45
miles away I was like miles 45 miles
away I think I said minutes 45 miles
away wow and I was like hell no are you
going to reimburse me are you
reimbursing me petrol who's checking my
mot make sure because that's a distance
and I was like that's you're asking me
to write off an afternoon Rags I'm not
writing enough I'm not driving an hour
and a bit there doing however long I
have to wait there doing my blood test
on an hour and a bit back it's pretty
much cross country bro I'm not doing it
so I was like uh and it was like 50 Quid
it was in a nastier yard paid the 50
Quid nurse came they send you another
pack which is like a V like a Venus one
now so not from the fingerprick anymore
bro bro so she comes over her name was
Maxine she was lovely she came over on
Saturday
um
one of these yeah and she's like how you
feeling I was like but that I'm not
gonna lie to you no I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm nervous I don't like blood tests
yeah give me a little vaccine minor yeah
I don't have a fear of needles there's
something about these man sticking it in
my face and fam you can hear it bubbling
in the vial when it's like you can hear
it and that's my that's my insides
that's my life force that's my life
force yeah you're bubbling away in there
I was looking I was looking at the
ceiling I was looking at the ceiling and
I was shaking like that and then she's
like it's done it's done I was like gang
and what made it worse she gave me a
little squidgy ball to squeeze and I was
like I don't want to squeeze it because
I know why you want me to squeeze
yeah
well it's a burst out
not my blood you wanted yeah you you
wanted to come willingly
you don't want to work for this
yes bro you want my insides to come to
you with a free will moving like some
Pied Piper nah bro you're gonna have to
take it yeah yeah so if Adam she grips
it from me and then afterwards she was
like oh if you feel faint or anything
like that it's fine
just wanted to scout I just want to just
get out you should put your plaster on
one second I'm sorry but get out I don't
look at your face anymore
so
so she left and then what made it worse
my arm was aching after it was charging
me it was it was not even like so
painful but it's just that effect I can
notice it okay and I just felt like even
though it wasn't that bad I felt like my
arm was flopping I can't train perhaps
it's impact someone give me sugar water
and sugar but I was like I can't do
anything yeah anyway
so organizing him this better work yeah
yeah suit Monday morning they email me
we've got your results okay I was like
bet opened it yeah yeah I was thinking
right
eventuality one in my head I'm like cool
here's scenario number one scenario
number one is they tell me James your
testosterone is dangerously low your
testosterone is dangerously low and the
reason you're fat and weak is is because
you've got no testosterone yeah yeah if
anything we're impressed you've made it
this far yeah how are you alive yeah
adrenaline I'm impressed that you're as
warm as you are because you've got
nothing going on yeah yeah yeah like you
need to sign up for some trt immediately
let's get your levels up yeah yeah and
then I would have been gassed I would
have gas shoot me up yeah yeah yeah give
me all the give me all the Jews because
I'm about to get massive yeah that's
eventuality number one
eventually number two was they'd say
yeah testosterone is actually [ __ ]
high to be fair James your testosterone
is high and in my head I'm like James
you've got high testosterone
why are you complaining yeah or the if I
had high testosterone in my head I'm
like all of these things are your fault
yeah this thing about you complaining
not losing weight you're complain about
this you're complaining that you're not
feeling strong enough or whatever that
you used to all of your fault mind games
because your your hormones are up if
anything you should be way bigger than
you are and it would have motivated the
[ __ ] out of me I promise you it would
have motivated the [ __ ] out of me okay
so I would have been like gang which
one's it gonna be
came back middle of the pack I swear
couldn't be more Central oh sweat it
literally might as well have been called
basic [ __ ]
middle swear not any lower not any
higher than it was smack bang 50 50 in
the middle basic [ __ ] average male wow
okay and I was like what am I supposed
to do with this where do we go from here
[Music]
so this is where we go okay this is what
me and remember talk about before okay
okay okay so anyway so I'm I'm deflated
scenario I'm depleted and I'm like what
am I supposed to do and I check all the
hormones okay middle middle middle
middle for everything I'm just an
average man
an average man with average height
and I was like wow wow okay yeah yeah
yeah I'm a number yeah I'm literally a
number yeah like I was looking at
fingers thinking the scientists won't
even remember doing this test
so I mean I'm middle of the past they
won't remember that they were fat they
won't know I was looking at their finger
there's nothing interesting nothing
stands out yeah I'm like I'm just a part
of their day I'm just like this
that's fine yeah 100 yeah there's like
the whole time he's doing it at no point
was he like under the microscope yeah
his eyebrow didn't do anything no no
point was that oh interesting yeah no
I'm just any brand China come see this
Blood like there's no point where he was
like how old is he and I had to go
through the go through the little thing
to check my my my phone yeah the Rolodex
he didn't have to go for the Royal decks
but James okay James okay [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's not making sense
you're playing the scenario right not
I'm thinking none of these things happen
I'm so basic yeah yeah so anyway
that's all done that's all done then I
was listening to
um
Andrew Schultz's podcast flagrant okay
the other day okay and they had my boy
Dr Andrew huberman on okay I love me
some Andrew huberman okay so for context
uh he is uh and I'm pretty sure he's in
he specializes in Neuroscience okay at
Stanford University I'm pretty sure
that's his day-to-day okay
but he is just Mr science anything the
same way uh what's his name Martin Lewis
is Mr money if he's on a show you're
thinking I'm gonna learn some money
stuff that I didn't think I needed to
know
Dr huberman when he comes on a show
you're going to learn science stuff you
didn't think you needed to know okay and
he's the kind of guy and he is all about
clinical research he knows the studies
he knows the research he doesn't think
about well he doesn't give his personal
opinion on anything he just gives you
facts that's what I love about him he
will never ever say well I think he'll
that would never come out of his mouth
it would be like the research shows this
or the research shows it doesn't and if
the research doesn't show it if there's
not a journal that he can cite or an
article that he can cite to say the
results he's just not going to speak on
it okay people like this just he said
there's just not enough studies that's
all they say there's just not been the
research that just hasn't been done
he'll never say I think or I believe or
anything like that Mr science sorry from
that I listen to it I basically listen
to everything he has to say all the time
probably shouldn't but I listen to
everything
so he's done a lot of talk about uh like
testosterone replacement he's done a lot
of talk about like the benefits of sleep
the benefit of diet the benefits of the
best way to train and Longevity and he
does all these things right yeah and
then he was on Schultz's podcast he was
talking about I would really really
recommend this into this episode it
starts off a bit shaky because they have
this very like
they have this really like
how to explain it mean girls scenario so
you watched it shots I've seen that
episode I'm saying in general okay yeah
yeah I know what you mean the way the
podcast is set up is like yeah yeah
there's shorts yeah there's Akash and
there's the the researcher and the
editor yeah
um Alex and I can't remember the other
guy's name the white guy's name who's
actually really interested and you have
the guest in the middle and then they
have a guess in the middle and it's kind
of like and they have so many personal
jokes that they throw around and I guess
it's always like like I want to be part
of the game but I'm obviously not and
sometimes it gets a bit jarring
especially when you have people that I'm
really interested in yeah it's not too
bad when they have other comedians on
there yeah because the comedian can like
pick up on it and just do that play
their part yeah yeah yeah when they have
scientists on there they have Mr Beast
on there they have other people that are
like interesting on there they just
don't know how to be part of the gang
and they just kind of sit there
awkwardly like waiting for the laughter
to subside yeah yeah and it gets tiring
sometimes but with this they had it for
like 15-20 minutes and I was like I was
this close to like I think I'm just
going to lock it off but it got good
okay it got good oh listen and um I was
worth it yeah
and towards the end Alex the editor
brought up peptides okay so as I was
saying um to REM I was saying that
basically so I used to go to the gym
um I used to go to the gym with this guy
called John right and that's the guy I
was messaging earlier okay so I used to
go to I used to go to gym with a guy
called John and he's Wham I'm constantly
if you if you've seen him before you may
or may not have met him before
um and that brings a bell though Wham
he's uh you might have seen him like
kind of short guy probably about five
seven massive beard white guy huge
maybe not then okay never mind maybe not
exclusively where's Jim leggings
exclusively exclusive Charles me no no
jars me but his legs are so jacked you
can't say anything okay fair enough yeah
he's not saying anything right because
if I had your legs I'd wear exclusive
leggings as well
um so anyway so yeah
um he's really really smart okay and
it's similar to like Cuban loves
research analysis loves like doing the
research on this thing John okay really
really looks uh is sorry is way smarter
than he looks okay um not just he
doesn't look smart but he's actually
crazy smart Okay and really really
scientific and he can research like
journals and articles and studies like
off the top of his head this is the way
people re flip in say Bible verses off
the top of their head he's coming up
with studies okay so he every time we
used to talk
he would never talk to me about gear but
one consistent topic and I'm talking
probably like four or five years ago one
consistent topic that would always come
up peptides okay anytime I had an issue
with something men were like you need
this peptide this did this and back then
I was terrified of needles so every time
I say peptides to me I've been thinking
stop talking because I'm not going to do
it yeah I'm not going to do it John I'm
not gonna do it you're wasting your
breath for me I'm interested but I I
struggle to keep interested because I
know this doesn't apply to me because
all I heard in the second ago was you
say needle and I'm done yeah and he was
a peptides peptides peptides and I
didn't I think I don't even know what
peptide is just run me gear or something
just tell me yeah just tell me how to
look at you and it'll say peptide
and I'm like oh for God's sake and then
I remember when I hurt my back
originally I went to the gym one day and
he's like I haven't seen you for a while
like what's going on and I was like oh
bro I think I've got like a herniated
disc like this that that and he was like
oh there's this peptide called such such
and as I forgot I need bit his head off
yeah for God's sake John yeah I'm not
stabbing myself yeah but he and he was
like I was really good because I had a
client who also had a similar back issue
she had two shots in the site of he was
like I remember him saying it was two
shots in the affected site and all I
heard was
stabbed me in my back yeah facts and all
I thought was paralyzed
so I was like dude I remember thinking
this is such a useless conversation
because I'm not putting anything in my
back you're crazy
affected science don't talk like that
don't talk like that to me John Bro I'm
streaking I'm tired of this guy yeah
yeah I'm not putting anything in my
spine bro never anyway so I moved on
from it
but for some reason whenever I think
about him I always think peptides yeah
and I've never thought about peptides
again yeah anyway move it this is how we
collect a flagrant so Alex is on there
and he's like oh but just before you
leave like I'm really interested in
peptides can you talk to us about
peptides human was like say less
because if human beings excited I'm
excited
yeah so anyway he's like say less so he
was like there's a lot of talk about
peptides there's all this or this and he
was like and one of the main ones is um
a peptide called cellar cellar a melon
or something like that okay and um he
started talking about it and he was like
basically this is like one of the
peptides that are very common in like if
we're talking about movie stars if you
see a movie star gets a Marvel movie all
of a sudden they're like it's like it's
a perfect Middle Ground a peptide is
like a perfect Middle Ground where he
described it
um obviously an actual peptide is like a
long chain amino acid sometimes like
very deep I've been researching all
weekend as you can tell
um so
basically he was like it's a perfect
Middle Ground between like your typical
supplements okay and steroids Okay and
like
it doesn't have a lot of kind of
androgenic effects and side effects that
steroids would have like your hair loss
or your voice is getting deeper or like
you're finding like growth
um and you're getting like gyno on your
boobs and all this horrible stuff and
like your bull shut down it doesn't have
those effects yeah but obviously you're
not going to get these extreme results
with the steroids you get extreme
results but Extreme side effects yeah
yeah with peptides is basically saying
like bro
the research is showing yeah there's a
couple one of them that he was he was
talking about was one called Sarah
maroon and basically what that does is
you inject it just before bed and it
gives you a massive release during your
sleep of human growth hormone
which
um
if people don't know who my girlfriend
is the growth hormone so it grows
Everything grows muscles but um also
they're random so it's quite well
Messi's human growth hormone was
affected where was a you he had to get
replaced or something that's why he's
small so really yeah I was watching
documentary that's another thing as well
so when people are affected there's
numerity like the tallest people in the
world and people that have like giantism
and stuff like that
um another one is uh what's his name uh
Tony Tony Robbins okay Tony Robbins um
so Tony Romo is like super super famous
like motivational guy has like seminars
and stuff like that anyway he's got like
giantism like massive hands super tall
massive hands massive [ __ ] head I
think it's like six seven six eight
something like that he's big and like
but he had an issue with his
uh whatever part of the brand I can't
remember what it's called
um
pituitary gland I think okay pituitary
gland I think is the one I could be
wrong
um that releases human growth hormone
okay so I'm assuming Messi would have
had something wrong with pituitary gland
um and on the flip side if you have a
growth or a tumor on your pituitary
gland it causes you to your brain to
excessively produce growth hormone and
you just grow and grow and grow and grow
and grow
um so that's what he had he had like a a
growth on his uh pituitary gland okay
um so anyway
growth hormone so anyway you take the
time yeah growth hormone through the
night and you don't want to take it
every day because obviously it reduces
the effectiveness on it but the also
reason you don't want to take it every
day is because it grows everything so if
you
um have for example a little tumor in
yourself a little tumor somewhere that
you don't know about you start taking a
growth hormone the tumor is going to
grow wow yeah yeah so one of the
potential side effects of this peptide
okay but if you don't then it won't yeah
yeah of course of course I guess we'll
find out yeah yeah okay so yeah if in
six weeks but basically what you're
saying is like if you want to get it you
need to get it from like really trusted
sources yeah yeah you can get like you
don't want to go into black market and
just like okay do some PayPal team or
some random rare you can get anything
um but this one intrigued to me this one
intrigued me and this one Andrew
huberman actually takes himself okay he
said I take it three three nights a week
he said just bang it okay and the
studies show like no long-term effects
as it is there's obviously side effects
with everything you do he was like this
one's pretty cool okay and I was like
gang and then on top of that he was like
oh there's another one called like I
can't remember what this one was called
but it's like really really good for
repair it's called like bv500 something
something like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah did you know what he said well he
was like I had this back issue
two shots in the affected sight never
had an issue since and I was thinking
John you son of a [ __ ] you were right
the whole time
you son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
damn he was right I should have done the
back thing because I'm five years later
still struggling yeah yeah I'm five
years and still struggling that being
said I don't think I can shank myself in
the back I just don't think I can
someone have to time yeah yeah yeah tie
me down legs yeah yeah my spine it licks
and arms bro yes I'll shake I'll shake
it don't miss so anyway
round it up a middle of the pack basic
[ __ ] when it comes to testosterone but
Daddy might do a little something a
little peptide thing yeah so
watch me now because in six weeks time I
could be warm and lean
but I also could have like a growth on
my face
if I see
it and your head is a little bit bigger
yeah
I could look like the bread from the 100
from 300. do you remember yes I do
weird little like sex Factory yes yes
yes everyone was a little bit like him
everyone's a little bit like him yeah it
was crazy he looked banging it out it
really did it was like a circus but it
was crazy anyway I was too young at the
time to watch that movie yeah because I
remember I probably I was in premium
like pbps okay and I yeah I just
remember like two women with their face
like together but it's just teeth and I
was like oh my God
um well by the time this comes out
probably won't be the most recent but
I'm pretty sure it's still the most
recent really fascinating episode they
don't just talk the peplus is like
probably the last 15 minutes other stuff
they talk about fascinating fascinating
I love Andrew huberman he's got also got
podcasts himself called huberman lab
it's pretty heavy he really gets deep on
some subjects and sometimes it can be a
bit like I don't I've lost yeah yeah
yeah it never existed yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're using three words to perform
a sentence and I don't know where any of
those words mean yeah yeah so it's like
yeah I don't know what I'm doing okay
but human has a bit much but yeah when
he guests on other people's podcasts
yeah he has to break it down yeah yeah
yeah and you're like I'm with you yeah
yeah yeah yeah brought me the peptide
okay
so I've been on the search for a dodgy
doctor that can prescribe us some sermon
okay because I can't remember what it's
called so
um yeah look at look out for me guys in
six weeks I could be Wham and just have
uh yeah yeah yeah yes so we'll see
um one other thing I want to say right
I've got story time for you okay hit me
no other stories have in a minute I
don't think yeah
so I had a fantastic situation in The
Barbers the other day Okay so obviously
I told you I had a Barber's appointment
it got canceled
um so I had to go to homeboy classic
homeboy that everyone knows that I have
a love hate relationship with yeah yeah
so I went to him I messaged him because
he said he just had ACL surgery so I was
like bro are you on your feet or not I
basically just text him what's going on
yeah yeah are you about you acting yeah
I need a haircut today yeah and he was
like yeah come through so I went through
and as I get there you went to the shop
he went to this I went to the shop
um I came through and he's cutting
someone's hair I go in and it's my old
friend kojo okay
and kojo who I haven't seen in such a
long time
is uh I saw what you've been buying
before he's a YouTuber you have church
yeah yeah yeah yeah so super Christian
guy yeah he has a YouTube channel
um where he talks about like
relationships does a lot of content on
like dating shows and all that kind of
stuff I think he's got quite a big
audience in America he told me and stuff
like that okay but basically he was like
my North Star when we were starting this
he was my North Star he was the only
person I've ever known who actually is
doing it yeah yeah making money doing it
making money from it yeah this is like
three years ago yeah wow I remember and
I would refer to him in everything yeah
yeah yeah and um he's giving me loads of
advice throughout throughout the time
here and like when I've really had my
struggles uh with like growing this
Channel and like growing our audience
and stuff like that I remember
probably like a year ago we were on 8
000 Subs I remember 8 000 subs and I and
we were stuck there for ages and I
remember saying to him
uh I I voice noted him and I was like
bro I'm not gonna lie to you I don't
really know what to do I don't know what
to try I don't know if we should just
stick to what we're doing and what we
know if we should be trying different
stuff I don't know if it's patterning
like there's a growth as of late it's
been really slow yeah and he just
replied real quick and was like brother
it took me three years to get to 8 000
Subs you're doing just fine just stick
with it okay and I was like okay say
less respect say less and he does
content every day on YouTube he posts
video most days oh wow he's busy hard
working breath
um
so yeah yeah I was I I saw him and I
haven't seen him at all yeah yeah in
years I've spoken to him I haven't seen
him in years I was so happy to see him
okay I'm so happy so I ran in there and
I was like yo yo can I get all Gruff
and he's like oh James and it was just
me and him in the shop yeah no one else
was in the shops Embrace each other like
yeah yeah we're just talking and um bro
we were in there just chopping it up and
it was like Wow and we were talking
about like this life just this life and
it was just to have someone else
we were not at an event and we're not in
that kind of situation to someone I grew
up with yeah to talk about these things
was so refreshing so refreshing I love
that for you and bro it was amazing and
um so we spoke about it we spoke about
YouTube we spoke about like live shows
we spoke about growing audiences the
struggles we spoke about the money we
spoke about just like Fame stuff we
spoke about everything man yeah and we
were talking for like over an hour just
non-stop Non-Stop and like it was cool
as well because obviously my barber's
been cutting my hair since I was a kid
he's been kind of courageous hair since
he was a kid yeah this Goji lives in
Birmingham
so he's been cut he's like he knows us
since we were kids as well and obviously
we're in the same year in school we went
to different schools we're in the same
year and the beautiful thing about kojo
is he's one of the most authentic people
you've ever meet right so this is what I
say it's a story time as well so I met
him in year nine okay I met him in year
nine right and um the day I met him
he was like I said he went to a
different school I was walking to the
shop after school with two of my boys uh
Robert and Perry I remember right Robert
and Perry I was walking down the shop to
the shop with them yeah and all of a
sudden I look across the road and I see
this
morbidly obese Ghanaian kid with the
thickest Dexter's Lab glasses I've ever
seen yeah yeah with these
um earphones in yeah and he is skanking
oh up the Rope by himself
thank him and I'm like and then I
remember Robin Perry were just like this
waste man and I've never seen him before
I know like oh here we go here's kojo
okay here we go here's kojo yeah yeah
and I'm like what who's this guy and
he's like he's just on Wasteland He Just
Dances all the time like I didn't
understand that why he does this right
it's embarrassing yeah and I remember
thinking about I was I was like yeah
yeah
bollocks he's happy he's loving life
right now I've never seen someone enjoy
life this embracing his own space and I
was like wow this guy's cool man he
looks like the biggest Knight but he
looks cool bro like I can't believe he's
got the balls to just be dancing on road
like this yeah and he's not even in his
ends yeah yeah yeah yeah he's in my ends
because his school's from time away as
well I don't even know what he's doing
up here yeah yeah
um
so anyway I met him briefly then
um
said cool introduce myself etc etc as
you do in year nine and he's talking to
our breath from another school you don't
really check for him like that you just
give him a little yeah
yeah
don't just don't let me see you here
again sorry let me catch you around
these parts
you know you know you shouldn't be here
you know that you know yeah yeah you
know the code yeah you at least get
changed out your school uniforms
yeah don't make me in a position where I
have to take action
I don't want to be put in that position
so don't put me in a position
I don't have to drop the badge off your
place yeah yeah um
so anyway
um moving on from there
um later on in life probably a couple
years after that I meet
um my friend who went to his school as
well called Jason who's at one of my
close basketball friends this is when I
got really really deep into basketball
and I got really really close with Jason
and um little did I know Jason was also
best friends with kojo okay so I get
reintroduced to kojo a few years later
he's still Mr skank he's still Mr happy
he's still just like this happiest guy
I've met and is like pure hearted lovely
guy yeah uh and like every time I met
him I was just like bro this guy is so
positive like he's so nice so positive
so cool uh he started getting into gym
lost loads of weight was just Wham and
bro and he's just like developing in his
life and I was like this guy's just cool
and as I followed his life he started
doing YouTube kind of like after uni
times
um
he started doing YouTube after uni times
and then like I remember being like raw
fair play and he started like in his
bedroom with like a really shitty webcam
and everything and he just kept doing it
kept doing he kept doing it and I kind
of lost touch with it man
um I didn't really check in for a good
few years until
I started yeah and then I would go on
Instagram and still see him posting
about his YouTube stuff and I was like
oh let me actually check and I remember
I checked and I think he actually might
have had like 8 000 Subs at the time
okay I think randomly I think that's a
weird connection I might be making it up
but I'm pretty sure it was about 8 000
subs and I remember thinking at the time
like oh my God it's a lot of followers
Bro you've got 8 000 Subs because we
might have had 12. yeah yeah and I was
like this guy's got eight how was it
when we started when you started your
first one I think it might have been
when we started okay I think it might be
when we started
um and I remember thinking ah this guy
is doing the most okay and I was
thinking he's actually getting paid for
this because in my head I'm thinking if
once you get to a thousand Subs you're
getting paid okay he's got eight times
that yeah he's getting he's making money
the YMCA and I remember maybe a year
after that maybe a little while after
that
he posted a screenshot from his YouTube
like studio app yes and had like the
graph of his growth yes and his like
Subs over time and stuff like that and
he was like today's the day I quit my
job I'm gonna be doing YouTube full time
and I remember we were so early on yeah
and I was like
wow he's really doing it he's really
doing it bro this guy's doing it he's
killing it and it motivated me so so so
so so so so much
um and then um moving on from there
obviously I had the conversation we were
eight thousand Subs at this point I
think it was like twenty thousand thirty
thousand and he was doing so well for
himself and I'm just like oh man I just
want to be like him and then throughout
that period of time like obviously our
success has taken off yes and um we've
just gone and gone and gone and I've
never ever ever forgot forgotten about
him and I still talk to him sometimes
but not as much as I'd like and um
as well another prop to him is obviously
due to our success on Tick Tock he spoke
to me about Tick Tock one time and I was
like yeah man do Tick-Tock there's no
reason why not to and I thought he was
going to do it
based on the relationship stuff he does
on his YouTube channel stuff like that
and I and all of a sudden I started
seeing his tick tocks and
um it's just him
doing year nine kojo stuff he's in the
gym just dancing okay and I'm like this
is him bro this is the real God this is
real him and I really liked it because
he you know when you're going Tick Tock
sometimes and you see people like on the
Underground they'll be on the
Underground in London or in New York or
whatever and they're doing up dancing on
the train yeah yeah and you're like oh
yeah yeah why are you begging it like
why would you do this yeah I know for a
fact that's actually him yeah because
I've seen that since I was a little kid
yeah this is the exact same guy and 15
16 years later he's still doing the same
thing and I was like Wow fair play
didn't think about it again checked on
it checked on it I think he posted about
it all about and he hit a hundred
thousand on Tick Tock I'm thinking wait
a second
so that's it you've done one form of
content over here and made it your
career and you're living off it and then
you've decided to do a completely
separate style of content on a
completely separate app and you've grown
an even bigger audience on that app and
I was like this guy's actually killing
it oh he's got a hundred thousand on
Tick Tock followers on Tick Tock
that video had a hundred thousand views
no no no no no oh he's got 100 over 100
000 on Tick Tock okay okay from
completely separate contents where the
stuff he's already built his whole life
around yeah yeah yeah and I was like
this guy's kidding it okay he's actually
killing it so when we're in the Bible
yesterday I was like bro you don't
understand like you're breaking the mold
yeah and he's like nah you're breaking
them
[Laughter]
yeah so um we had this conversation yeah
and um as I'm thinking about all these
reminiscent things about how much
he's meant his career has meant to me
yeah and what my friendship with him has
meant to me yeah growing up yeah up
until where we're at right now and how
big of an influence he was to me uh in
terms of becoming a success and what we
do I'm reminiscing all these things
feeling so much joy and it's at the same
time
I may have or may not have spoken to you
about this I I don't think I actually
have but recently I've found myself in a
really really negative this is getting a
bit deep before we usually do but
whatever
I've recently found myself in a really
negative space probably over the last
month and I've allowed I've allowed
stress to get on top of me okay okay and
I've allowed myself to be a reactive
person I've not been responding I've
been reacting okay anything that bad
happens I'm just like that's the end of
the work yeah why is this happening why
can't things just run smoothly I'm just
getting stressed and stressed and
stressed and I'm not enjoying stuff and
I'm not enjoying challenges yeah and I
remember I had to sit down myself and I
was like you know what I really need to
start practicing gratitude like I should
be grateful for everything we have I
should be grateful for the challenges
that happen
um and then we had this little hiccup on
YouTube like last week or beginning of
this week Sunday whatever with the
demonetization stuff and all this stuff
and that would be the way I've been the
last few weeks that would be such a
moment where I'm like oh my God what
next is that a problem yeah yeah but I
was like
gang yeah new challenge okay they're
still with it yeah we've dealt with a
million challenges up to here there was
a time in our career where we just gave
up on YouTube facts we're like we're
never going to make money we're never
gonna make money we're never gonna be
monetized yeah yeah all our videos so
let's just stick to patreon let's stick
to this let's stick to that let's figure
out ways around it yeah and it was never
making money on YouTube was never a
barrier for us and now we found
ourselves in a position where I'm like
oh my God oh my God oh my God so when it
happened instead of overreacting like I
have been and complaining I was like
gang Let's find let's figure our way
around this yeah there is a way around
it let's figure our way around it and
just get the best of both worlds
and I've been enjoying that all week and
it's only been literally this week that
I've been practicing for actually
practice about and then when these
hiccups happen I've not been stressed
I've been cool challenge this is
competition challenge challenge
challenge challenge and I'm a
competitive person and to bring it back
to kojo like I said as I'm reminiscing
and all this stuff about his life and my
relationship with him he's saying to me
like bro you don't understand like
growing up you were always that
competitive guy like you were so
competitive about everything like every
time I'm dancing you'll be you'll come
back from uni with all these like
skankins you're so competitive like yeah
you wanted to come back like oh look at
this doggy thing yeah do you remember I
always come back like oh yeah watch this
new movie
and he was like James you're so
competitive like every time I'd have
something you'd be like yeah watch this
watch this yeah and like when he started
he's like when I start getting into gym
all of a sudden I'm looking on Instagram
and you're doing bodybuilding shows
you're doing that and it's like you're
so competitive always driven driven
driven driven and then you start this
YouTube thing and then all of a sudden
bang like you start this Tick Tock thing
and listen bang like you've always been
to me he's like James you've always been
to me this guy that I look to and be
like when James starts something like he
goes for it that's wholesome fam and
it's happening in this transitionary
period in my life where I'm thinking I
need to be like that yeah and they made
me think he's saying all these praise to
me I'm thinking if he knew what I've
been acting like the last month or so
he'll be disgusted he'll be like who is
this brand
and he's like he has all this stuff
going on for him and all he's doing is
complaining about baby little [ __ ]
and bro like yesterday was such a
wholesome day for me yes it was such a
wholesome day for me bro such a awesome
day only had like an hour or so
conversation bro over the course of that
hour I went for a roller coaster of
emotions yeah and I came out of it
feeling so fulfilled you felt cleansed I
felt cleansed bro yeah yeah and then I
got into my RS5 and sped off
[Laughter]
so yeah anyway it was a great great
conversation a great experience
um and yeah bro I was gassed I was very
whole gas bro okay so what I'm gonna do
I never do this but what I'm gonna do um
I want to send everyone to his channel
you have to let him know I sent you
because he can't just get bear Subs yeah
I think for no reason yeah I need the
receipts yeah so
I need the price I need to resist yeah I
need a DM for him to be like wrath thank
you so much you've changed my life
hilarious so anyway his name is kojo his
channel is little black book 91 I think
let me just double check because I
checked before here but I just want to
make sure I'm saying it right yeah it
will be popped up yeah and this is going
to Chuck it on there so little black
book 91 or one word
um he does literally like daily streams
daily content he pumps out the content
and he's been doing it for years and
years and years so guys head on over to
the channel throw him some love for me
but if you do for the love of God let
him know I sent you you have to say here
from James again or hear from gigs
because I can't just let him have free
money like that
anyway um that's love man shout out to
kojo because yeah he's been a massive
inspiration in my life in my career and
everything like that and he deserves
literally the world he literally
deserves the world you know what's
actually crazy about life like if
obviously
um those that no or don't know we now
have the same Barber but if he didn't
cancel yesterday that's what I'm saying
you never would have had this
conversation never would have had this
conversation never would have saw him
yeah it never would have sworn this
whole outlook on not necessarily life
but this a whole outlook on these past
few years or past few months and you
reminisce into when he you were in year
nine this one never would have happened
oh I know bro that's crazy yeah Sam
would have come to my house cut my hair
we've had a little change
you would have been still thinking about
this yeah I would have come in like
what's going on in there yeah yeah oh
yeah it was crazy it was really really
crazy really really good moment I it was
it was lovely to see him yesterday
lovely to see you today bro really
really great awesome yeah incredible oh
the best uh anyway back to it you got a
video for me apparently yes I do so let
me find it and then we can go from there
all right cool so for context guys
um for the audio listeners it's a video
of
um a chick talking about um light skin
privilege and it's um what's her name
again
because she's blown up so quick
um and then a video
um there's a chick talking about oh say
this light skin privilege Barbara but
the guy replies to saying
[Music]
that's an instant juice
for the audio listeners man was shaking
his body bro the bite he was wiggling
just let me watch your problem what's
your property and I read the comments
skin privilege is the fact that she was
blown up overnight but Flo Milly who's
actually insane nah bro she hit one of
these she hit one of these little
instant Jones
his cheeks were clapping bro for the
comments oh you said Hey in the comments
comments comments my brother in Christ
throw it back some more
massive for free for free
be honest Brody did you practice that
that shit's moving
I said now why is your joint so active
probably one person he's definitely
holding back
that spun me that spun me he's
definitely holding him back bro hit 30
million views proving his point oh man
said all that recoil
bro Tick Tock comments are the best
that's the funniest Place bro oh my dad
yeah that video sweeted me I don't even
know why he pra why he knows how to do
that bro it doesn't make sense I said he
hit one of these insta drawers it's some
John's the terms
whenever someone says it sweets me oh my
God but yeah
comments there's there's gonna have to
be a time I've I wrote this in my notes
a while ago there's gonna come a time
when we do some content yeah that is
pure Tic-Tac comments pure Tick Tock
comments because they are better than
the video oh Rags Rags 100 that's that's
gonna be something we're gonna do cool
um but anyway I've got just a couple
just to finish off my favorite tweets of
the week
there's one or two of these bro I've
literally only got like three or four
okay one or two of these bro had me Ben
up had me
Ben are sayless
so this is actually I saw some of these
the the thread that I saw it on yeah was
uh at the shade room posted it and it
was like
um the most out of pocket tweets of the
week okay the most out of pocket tweets
of the week okay one breath said just
lost
just lost custody of my kids what's the
move for tonight
this one killed me
right see it sunset this one sweet me
because this don't speak to me because I
thought as I was reading yeah I thought
what I was reading as I was reading it
okay do you remember like I had a
thought like what and then as I'm
reading what it's like what yeah
sorry
yeah yeah
the tweet
no matter how old they get yeah women
like Nia Long Ashanti and Whoopi
Goldberg will always be on top of
everyone's Hit List man's quoted it and
who
[Laughter]
and who facts I read that and thought
exactly the same thing exactly when I
was reading it I saw the whoop I was
like and this sort of thing and who
hilarious to me bro hilarious Ashanti
and Whoopi Goldberg
said and who
oh my God all right last one
oh
um so tweet and then reply to our own
tweet here yeah yeah I tried talking to
her all right I tried talking to a
creative fashion guy yeah and he asked
me what's the fit looking like when I
invited to my Grandpa's funeral
the question itself wasn't necessarily
the issue but it was the delivery
when he asked this and the follow-up
when he when he asked this the follow-up
was we get Fly any occasion
any occasion
what's the fit looking like for a
funeral do you want to come to my
grandad's funeral with me what's the fit
looking like I'll be so rattled I'd I
would swipe and delete the conversation
you're not a serious human being bro
you're not a serious human being and the
fact that he followed her up with such
chest I actually have he would be back
in my good books after that
my grandpa's just died to funerals on
Wednesday do you want to come say less
what's the fit looking like pardon yeah
yeah what's the fit looking like I said
what I said we get Fly any occasion I
know what you're thinking I know what
you're thinking with this pardon yeah
you heard what I said yeah yeah what's
the fact you think I'm just gonna rock
up just because someone's dying I can
just look busted what's the fit because
I want to leave people with a with a
sweet taste in their mouth
I wanted people to leave their thinking
the Wake was awful but who was that
bread yeah he was looking flying
literally who's that brother is that
Sarah because that pinstripe that golden
black wakanda forever pinstripe was
looking mad
you get Fly we get flight no matter the
occasion bro and that's the end of that
fair enough tell me what the Fitters are
sharp fair enough but yeah and who from
the and who was the funniest tweet I've
seen this month
I laughed out loud if you had yeah and
who thanks hilarious practice Goldberg
Whoopi Goldberg
I know if it's that props to heard of
everything she does but you can't put in
the same bracket as a knee along and
Ashanti you can't put her in anywhere
near a bracket nowhere near that she's
like bro
we're neither she's like not even ninth
draft pick yeah yeah bro she's not even
in this season's dropping she's going
Summer League
she's doing that silly bro she's doing
up G League bro facts [ __ ] swags it's
about to flash on her way here yeah yeah
yeah and even then she's riding the
bench in fact she's not even Sixth Man
yeah she's not bro that was wild to me
but anyway guys
um a little bit different start of
episode for today thank you so much for
sticking around with us
um as always head on over to patreon.com
sheets and Geeks to get the bonus
episode on Thursday and to binge watch
everything we've ever done always love
love
[Music]